start the live stream
and welcome to the career master class
most effective job hunting strategies
for tech jobs in 2021
speaker today is uh who has just
joined terapay as their new global head
of hr and administration
in a moment a quick orientation to the
controls
of webex please ask your questions for
vinay
in the q a box we do those up for
him at the q a section of the
presentation toward the end
anything you put in chat you may not see
unless you address it to all panelists
make sure that you do address your chat
to all panelists
and also be doing
quick polls beginning and end of the
presentation
so what we want to do here start with
this one and
launch the poll here
and this is a quick poll about your
experience
a chance to understand the audience
better
and also we've been asking this question
since the start of the pandemic
how are you feeling today so
answer both parts of this question
got about 20 seconds left
i answered that as well
three two one
are the pull results
see that we have a
fairly even distribution of experience
but
a good representation of people with
more than 10 years
as well as some people who are still in
school
fortunately most people are feeling
well or paid today for the rest of you
we hope that this presentation
brings you some information that you can
use to
prove your mood about your job prospects
for 2021-2022
i'm going to introduce now who you see
on your screen
as i mentioned he has just joined
terra pay as the global head of hr
administration
um he has over 15 years of experience in
the field of talent management
helen engagement talent acquisition he's
worked
in i.t banking insurance
and fintech sectors and tarapay
is a digital payments infrastructure and
solutions provider
so it's in the business of helping
consumers exchange money we can't hear
you very clearly
uh i think you have to be a little cloud
ah
probably the positioning of the
microphone yeah
apologize for that but uh i'm going to
turn it over
to vinay i'm going to stop
sharing my screen and
let him take over the presentation
so welcome vinny thank you very much for
being here
thank you thank you for uh having me
over
um it's a pleasure to be interacting uh
today with so many people and seeing how
we can together work
on better job strategies
and you know we're focusing on job
searching so
talking about things like what tech jobs
will be in demand
this year and beyond and where to look
for those jobs
and so um i understand you will be
sharing your presentation
let me just share my
[Music]
presentation
i'm guessing people are able to see
the presentation
yes we are excellent you know um
the first part to effectively looking
for an opportunity
is um how do you build
uh your story and how is it that you are
able to
share your story with people so
i'm going to be uh spending um
this next one hour on um
helping a lot of you uh by giving
tips on how can you share um you know
your story and what is it that you
should do
to effectively look for a job um
it's going to be a good one hour with a
lot of tips ladies and gentlemen
and definitely i'll try and answer as
many questions as possible you can keep
the q a
section pretty warm by by you know
continuing to post your questions
as you go through this particular
presentation
um to set a tone for our conversation
i think we're going to have a frank
conversation
we'll make it engaging with a lot of
examples and a lot of things that i will
keep
uh you know sharing about effective uh
you know job hunt strategies
and and also giving you some tips of
what skills are going to be hard
how is it that you're going to go ahead
uh in looking for them
there are also going to be some things
that are going to be hard hitting
uh because truth be said we need to know
the reality
we cannot expect everything to to fall
uh into our lab there is got to be work
that we have to do and we have to be
honest to ourselves so the conversation
is going to also be around that so this
is the tone
uh you know we'll keep it as frank we
will keep it as engaging and engaging
means it's a two-way street so
i would look forward to certainly um
talking to all of you and answering your
questions and hard hitting that's my job
i need to tell you the fact so that's
how it's it's going to be right
while we get into this whole you know
strategy
it's important that all of us understand
the context of the world we are living
in
right we're living in a world which is
overloaded with information news
words like unprecedented uh we have all
pretty much become virtual human beings
so online learning
i mean uh if you look at the last one
year
the amount of information we have
consumed just
by virtue of staying home we sometimes
take a break by not
looking at any gadgets because um
uh you know it's it's just too much of
overload of information
right news has honestly been um
a bane more than a boon because a lot of
people have had anxiety
issues because they kept reading news
and that also
made an impact on how they were
performing at their jobs
that made an impact on how effectively
they were looking for opportunities
that made an impact on how they could
build themselves up so definitely this
is the world we're living in which is an
overloaded world
um webinar right i mean
we're all uh on a webinar trying to
understand a lot of things
uh we have uh
you know uh all of us just went berserk
in the first six months of the pandemic
uh
which is uh you know starting off
feb march of last year uh to about
august september when everybody was on
webinars either you are
presenting on webinars for people like
us and people like you
who want to listen and consume knowledge
we had fomo which is fear of missing out
so
everybody wanted information we've i
think somewhere made peace with it and
now we know
what and how um you know we are able to
um sort of uh deal with online content
but this is a reality
and predictions oh my god are you going
to go back to work
from september 2020 are we going to go
back to work
from jan 2021 or no i think there's
another wave are we gonna now go back to
work
um you know from august
2021 september 2022 we
you know we have been predicting like
like you know as if we have all the
powers
right we've been talking of how
workplaces are going to change how life
will change
while we're getting used to a certain
lifestyle ourselves
so uh this is the context of the world
we are living in which
i would say is the new normal uh which i
would say
is here to stay and which will change in
in
at most a hybrid fashion uh but i
thought it's important that
uh a context is shared with all of you
so that uh
you know we all understand you know we
are all overloaded with a lot of things
we are fatigued
we are tired we want to break we want to
break the monotony so on and so forth
right um having said that
um it's important that um
we understand the three pillars of how
one should build a story
and obviously this webinar is to help
you with some tips and not just
give you information that you already
know um
by the way let me let let me give you a
little secret there's nothing that i'm
going to say
you're not aware of but what i'm going
to say
is help you organize the thoughts that
you're already aware of
so there's a difference you know when
you have everything cluttered like if
your wardrobe is cluttered it's
difficult to find information
that's how if your mind is cluttered
it's difficult to get
the right information you know when
you're giving an interview
or when you're talking to somebody or
when you're trying to do something
so what i'm going to do is an attempt to
help you organize that space which will
help you in an effective job search
strategy
while we talk about different hot skills
etc etc
right while this is going to be tech
specific but
honestly uh conversation interview
discussion is a human to human
discussion and therefore
a lot of these vectors are common across
uh
it's just that how your story is
different
and how you present that that makes a
whole whole lot of difference
right um the first thing that i want all
of you to do
if you're you know looking i i saw that
they were about 30 percent university
students they were like a 20
you know zero to four years five years
uh
you know there's so many of you with
varied experiences
um an essay is a very powerful tool
to help you with your life story
when i say that you you have to write an
essay about yourself
you have to start by writing your life
story as if it's a movie
yeah i know it sounds pretty dramatic
that uh you know how do i
you know really really do that um
but the beautiful thing of of writing an
essay about yourself
is it will pictorially or
visually it'll take you back in time of
what all you have done
and how much you've achieved and how
much you've learned
so when you look at writing your essay
you have to start from your school days
you know and and the essay should cover
essentially three things
what were your achievements what were
your failures
what were your learnings i will repeat
what were your achievements
what were your failures and what were
your learnings start writing from school
like for example when i
and i keep adding to my essay because
you know we are growing and we are doing
new new things so i i keep doing that
um i've written how i've learned by
failing in an exam how i have uh
been thrilled when uh i
i got say a first prize in a competition
uh how
i actually learned not to do things
which our parents have told so many
things that i've tried
start in that order from your school
life bucket your life in school life
graduate life and working life even in
working life
have a five year window of buckets you
know first five years second five years
then depending on how you progress
because you're also maturing in those
years in your work so your
responsibilities
are going to be different at different
stages
higher at higher levels so
start with writing an essay about
yourself just write an essay right
um what this will do
at the end of it is a you would have
lived through a beautiful life that you
would portray
beautiful miserable full of learnings
full of failures full of achievements
a mixed bag of multiple things it could
be many things but
that essentially is giving you
arms and ammunitions of experiences
that you can throw at your interviewers
i will repeat
when you have an essay written you have
a bag full
of experiences that you remember so if
somebody says tell me two failures
you have two failures oh you want two
failures i'll give you three failures
tell me the biggest learning in your
life you'll say oh i have four different
learnings and i would like to talk about
in four different jobs the kind of
things i've learned right
achievements i'm no longer um
just you know remembering my latest
achievement but i actually
in a chronological order remembering a
lot of my past achievements as well
so what i'm doing is this
essay as an activity is helping you
build this
why do we fail in interviews most of the
time so why do we not
work well in our job search or why is it
that we don't clear our interviews
is not because you're bad most of the
times it is because we do not remember
the right
things that we've got to tell the
interviewer
this will help you organize that so the
first thing that you have to do and this
is an activity for everybody
is to write an essay about yourself it's
a very powerful tool
i do that once every year and i keep
adding my experiences
i obviously have a long essay but you
know you start off and you keep adding
experiences
you will have better chances of doing
your interview well
also when you document about your life
a lot of things we do in life we don't
remember you know it's a part on process
but suddenly one day you realize oh my
god i had
been through that situation and i
actually you know managed to
kill the crisis by doing this doing this
for the client by developing this code
by writing it in this manner so on and
so forth so
this is the first activity that all of
you have to do
once you've written your essay the next
thing is
again a million dollar question and this
is very simple guys right
all of you keep having this debate oh i
keep doing certifications is it of any
use
simply don't i mean this platform is
going to kill me uh if i have to say
anything more about it but
right is this valid is the certification
helpful
should i do this certification or not
right
the only thing that you need to do is if
you
are doing any certification either free
of cost or by paying money
if you do any course either through
these webinars or through actual
programs that you go through
you have to have a book a journal
i mean i have kept a book myself while
i'm you know with you guys
so that i can make my notes when i learn
something right
you have to every course if you've done
10 certifications
each of the certifications you should
have two or three learnings that you
document
what i'm again doing is consciously
organizing
yourself in a manner that your
certifications become powerful
and they stand up for you when somebody
asks you what did you do in that agile
certification what do you do in that
scrum master certification what do you
do
in that python developer certification
oh you're a aws certified uh
professional what did
what what does that mean you know how do
you really work
on um you know amazon web services so
if you have two learnings per
certification and when somebody asks you
what did you do
you have that power of telling them
immediately the minute you tell somebody
about your learnings in a certification
or a course
that person on the opposite side is
going to take it seriously
but if you tell that person oh i did
that certification four years back
i don't remember too much of it is that
person going to take you seriously
of course not therefore these
certifications are brilliant
these courses are amazing because they
keep enhancing your knowledge
but the fact that you're not able to
tell that
is demeaning you in your own efforts to
crack
a conversation therefore you should
thumb rule any certification i do in my
life any course any program i enroll
i am going to have two distinct
learnings and possibly one learning that
i
implemented in my life written down in a
journal or a log book
and every time before i go for an
interview i will flip those pages
and just go through it so if somebody
asks me hey you did this certification
on behavioral
um uh interview technique or due to this
certification on anger management or
either certification on communication
skills etc etc
right what did you learn out of that
damn if you tell them
what did you learn out of that i or
anybody who is going to be on the other
side is going to take you seriously
right so to build your story there are
only three powerful things actually
ladies and gentlemen not too many
first is to write an essay an essay is
nothing but you write down your life
story in a manner where you
talk about your achievements your
failures your learnings your experiences
and just write down that doesn't have to
be in any order write down in in
whatever you remember
chronological is better from school to
current is better
but you can take a call if you want to
go from current to back to your
childhood or however else that you want
to do
but write it down that will give you a
lot of arms and ammunitions of
learnings of um failures of achievements
of experiences blah blah blah blah blah
and these are
things that we fumble on technically
nobody fumbles on things right
they ask you some technical question if
you're working on a code you will tell
what java springboard is
you will tell what a a manual test
script is
you will tell what an automated how do
you run an automation
you know test so of course you're going
to be strong in technicality
when it is these are elements that
sometimes do not allow you to crack your
interview conversations or look out for
opportunities right when people say
oh he's very good in technical but
otherwise he did not come across as a
confident candidate
like what are they trying to say they
are saying that you don't have a hold of
what you are
therefore this will help you in that
right secondly
your certifications and courses thumb
rule two learnings
and possibly one thing that you've
implemented right
the minute you write it down ladies and
gentlemen you will remember it for the
rest of your life
because that experience is fresh and
every time you flip pages
that whole story comes alive and that
helps you in talking confidently
now when you do all of this the uh
though not a side effect but the outcome
of this activity is confidence
because the minute you're able to answer
these things the confidence increases
the minute you're not able to answer
questions your confidence decreases it's
like you know
crossing levels in in different uh in in
a game when you have to cross different
levels right your confidence increases
when you
cross a tough one then next one you and
when you fail you realize you fail
because
you are over confident right or you're
under confident so
this will help you also increase your
confidence right the last thing which
is the simplest simplest thing
which i very firmly believe in
is to remove global jargons don't write
rosy things in your profile
in your cv don't talk of rosy thing i
am enthusiastic uh technological
professional
i want to i mean remove all global gap
or global jargons
because the more you keep it simple
straight forward the higher is going to
be the impact of your story
because your story is impactful when
they believe
that it is truthful your story is not
impactful
because they believe you can speak very
well
right i may be speaking very well but i
may not have a very impactful story if i
have not done these things
right so keep it simple and that's very
difficult because
all of us keep thinking oh objective you
know when you have cv everybody has an
objective
that objective is a copy paste of google
search oh my god i don't even know why
people write objective i don't even
think you guys know why do you write
objective because you've just seen it
somewhere
it feels nice you write an objective but
when somebody asks you
oh what is that in your objective that
you've written oh sir that because
everybody wrote we also wrote
and if you're not serious about yourself
how are they going to take you seriously
so these are
small small things that you should take
care of i will i will
i will stop
sharing answer any questions on this
part
if there is any before i move to the
next section uh while i know q a
is in the end but if there is one or two
questions that i could uh
i could you know possibly use the q a
section to
here i will try and either
attempt to answer or we'll move okay
there's like there's a couple of uh
questions that came in
through the chat and q a having to do
with the essay
um there's a question from centauri who
asks how many words
should be in the essay what will the
employers have any time to read the
essays and i think
you have you have a take on what the
essay is for
right that's a great question sanchari
and for everybody else
the essay is personal to you the outcome
of the essay is what you showcase you're
not going to
show this essay to anybody it's your
life story that's your
background of all the arms and
ammunitions of your experiences and
learnings and
progress and growth right that you're
not going to share everything with
everybody
you may only share two relevant ones in
a certain interview you may share two
others in another interview
so the essay should not have any word
limit it's your essay and you do the way
you want to do it
you don't show it to anybody okay so
yeah that's
okay um muhammad asks
what if we have fewer achievements or
how will that affect our
confidence level oh sorry i didn't get
that question
yeah i'm sorry muhammad asks
what if we have fewer achievements how
will that impact our confidence level
so if you have fewer achievements
doesn't matter
what matters is how you're able to tell
that how you're able to remember that
and how confident you are about those
achievements i may have just two or
three noteworthy achievements
but if i'm confident of those three
achievements and i tell that
my job is done so don't worry about how
many achievements you have
but worry about how you are able to
confidently share those achievements
with people
okay and i think you probably address
this when we get a little farther in but
we have questions on
how to deal with uh interview questions
like
weaknesses
there's a whole section on how you
should prepare for interview this is
a prelude to your interview conversation
uh broken down interview as well in a
very simple term and i shared that in
the presentation
i see a lot of people asking objective
objective objective right
my take is very simple ladies and
gentlemen if you want to write an
objective
believe in that second remember that
third proudly states that i will repeat
if you want to write an objective
believe in that remember that
state that i do not have an objective on
my cv
there's no right or wrong answer it's an
approach if you want to write
a ideally every job application
you should have an objective which is
different because
the outcome of that job may be different
for example i'm an hr professional
if i'm applying for a recruiting job i'm
going to write my objective as a
recruiter
if i'm applying for an hr business
partner job i'm going to write an
objective as an hr business partner
so if you write an objective like i said
believe in it
remember it and talk about it proudly
otherwise it's okay if you don't write
i'll go back to the presentation and
take some more
and objective statement everything is
the same you can write a statement but
believe in it remember
it talk about it objective believe in it
remember it talk about it
every word of your profile you should
remember and you should know why you've
written that
you cannot surprise when somebody asks
you a question on what you've written in
your own profile
as simple as that i'll go back to
sharing and we'll take more questions
[Music]
okay
excellent
yeah you know a lot of the next question
is how do i approach building my profile
right and some of you have been asking
you started asking how many words what
do i say and all of that right
they're only simple do's and don'ts okay
i'll talk of don'ts first
right don't do anything which is a tick
box
activity when i say a tick in the box
activity
it means that don't write
don't say or don't do anything
that you believe i have to do it because
it's a tick mark activity
this is my personal belief because that
makes a weaker profile a weaker
personality
right now uh does it mean that oh is
graduation tick in the box no it's not
that's a basic requirement
of you moving to the next level right uh
that's not what i mean by tick in the
box activity tick in the box activities
just because everybody is writing 10
certifications i'm also going to write
10 certifications
tick in the box activities like just
because everybody's writing an objective
i'm also going to write an objective
take in the box activities just because
everybody's profile has
you know a lot of things written in the
job
responsibility i will also write a lot
of things in a job responsibility
don't do it write what is real write
what is you
write what you have done if it means
like somebody you know muhammad asked
oh i only have a few achievements so
what be proud of your achievements
right be proud of who you are and
represent yourselves well
that is important so tick in the box is
is exactly that herd mentality
i don't need to explain heard mentality
right we all have been victims of that
just because everybody is doing this
like suddenly everybody says
oh i think ruby on rails is going to be
hot
you can't hear me can you hear me
charles
okay now somebody just pinged saying
they can't hear great sorry about that
so third mentality is just because
somebody says that
oh data analytics or data science is
going to be the next big thing
so i have to do that well you need to
understand the trends and
and possibly pick up on them but it
cannot be because
everybody is doing that you're doing
that right especially to a lot of
engineers from india who are
listening in today right we've all been
a part of the wave
herd mentality because people have told
this is what you have to do
right they've done mechanical
engineering we've done chemical
engineering we've done electronics in
communication but we're doing
software jobs or we are you know testing
um
or you know getting bugs tested on codes
written by somebody and getting
frustrated
right well it's important to recognize
this
and if you're building your profile then
try
not having a heard mentality okay simple
only two don'ts not too many i don't
like to give too many because
uh you know we're all used to don't do
this don't do this don't do this we'll
talk of do this do this do this more
than what we should not do
the do's are again um very simple
you need to have a focused approach
when i say a focused approach i'll give
you an example
you may be attending five different
interviews on one day
but that does not give you the right
that does not give you the right to tell
the interviewer or sorry you have not
gone through the job description when
you are
attending a particular interview focused
approach means that
you give your 100 to what you do
while technically we prepare we goof up
on these things
oh i haven't read too much about the
company oh this is the fourth interview
i'm giving
right don't do that because you never
know which interview is going to be the
best one or which interview is going to
get you a job or which conversation is
going to be interesting
therefore it is important that
for every conversation you give your 100
percent
simple thing that you have to do is keep
this notebook that i keep you know
lifting it every now and then
right before you go for that interview
write down
what the company is about write down the
three things in the job ensure that you
as an individual are aware focused
approach
right common sense um well we all
you know keep saying common sense is not
so common
but a lot of things that you do in a
conversation is common sensical
now you ask me how is it common sensical
to go
look for a job right i would say that if
you're going for a conversation or if
you're looking for an opportunity
you should have the common sense to
understand what that opportunities and
how you fit in
if you don't have that but you you
forcefully try to fit yourself
in and you get a negative answer and you
get demotivated
that's where you're not using common
sense it is important to read job
descriptions ladies and gentlemen at
least three times
and not convince yourself of things you
have not done saying that oh i can do
this and i will try and convince
right use common sense use your
discretion we all have that
it's stored very well in our head we
just don't like to use it very often
right um it is important that you know
i've seen a lot of techies struggle
saying oh i'm not a social media person
um oh i don't like going on linkedin i i
don't like doing this
you see the world has changed and as
techies
you guys are working on making this
world a
highly hyper connected uh place to be
in right nobody gave us training on
instagram facebook nobody gave us
training on snapchat nobody gave us
training
on creating reels we did it by ourselves
right the same needs to be applied for
linden
every day you have to be a little active
when i say active
it means consciously engaging on these
platforms
it is important that being the techies
who are making this world a hyper
technology
world you also be active on these
portals
job portals the way you have to be
active is very simple i'll give you a
simple trick
for job portals okay it is um
everyday morning go to nokri.com
just update your phone number every day
when you're very very actively looking
for a job do it every day
when you're looking for a job but not
very actively do it once a week
but you should simply go on your
high risk updates i am jobs nokri.com
monster career builder
there are so many job portals that are
available and you may be active or you
may have posted your profile on many
you have to every day just go and update
your phone number
just rewrite your name again and save it
what it does
is it puts your profile on the top of
the stack for that day
which means that you because you guys
build
artificial intelligence algorithms right
so the ai built there
is that somebody who's been active last
in first out in the sense somebody has
been active latest
that means that person is currently
looking for an opportunity somebody
somebody's active
one month back that means maybe he's got
an opportunity right
so it's important that you use that
common sense
of ai that you know a lot of techies are
building and do this
it's a simple tip it's a trick right and
it's funny that i'm i'm taking this to
the techies because you are the ones who
are building it uh for all of us for for
all all of us as consumers right
so um it's important that you do that
and
active on linkedin linkedin is going to
be definitely
very helpful in job searches i actually
write a lot on linkedin
and i've got applications by somebody
commenting on my post and them getting a
job as well
these are real scenarios i'm talking
about so
if you understand this very very simple
thing of how you should
prepare for every conversation and not
give a lazy reason that oh i attended
four interviews
so what if i don't remember you should
look at my technical skills and hire me
sorry if you're not serious i have 100
other people who are serious
right focused approach common sense
start using that more often
be active on these platforms very
important very critical
i hope i am going in at a reasonable
pace and people are able to understand
um and i'm hoping everybody's wide awake
in india and everywhere else listening
to what i'm saying excellent
you could just say yes enjoying extra
class will
make me feel alive because i feel like
i'm talking to myself
you know on the computer screen uh
everybody else has just switched off
their videos
so you know
i can assure you that you're getting a
lively stream of comment
questions excellent excellent excellent
right let's move on because then we'll
spend a lot of time on questions so i
would uh
you know move straight into um
how do you prepare for interview there
are really only
five sections ladies and gentlemen in my
view
again i've used common sense but largely
just about five sections and they are
right
um first
right you can take a screenshot of this
take a printout
before every interview just go through
this you will definitely definitely
crack it and you'll crack it easily
right
who are you right um that's the first
section
which is what's your personal uh
background what's your educational
background and
possibly if you have some interesting
hobbies right hobbies can't be
oh i like to binge watch and web series
i mean that's not a hobby that's
basically
you're wasting away your life
why do i say kiss because i want you to
keep it short and simple
we don't want to know how you played
cricket
or how you played baseball or how you
played hide and seek in your childhood
we are generally trying to have a
conversation it's a conversation starter
so your first section which is your
personal background educational
background and
your hobbies should be wrapped up in say
one minute one minute 15 seconds
if i have to give you an example and
i'll do a quick uh
um i'll do a quick one i'll share this
entire presentation with simply learn
and they can share it with you guys so
you can use it
don't worry uh you know if that's a if
they have that possibility they will
they'll do this and anyways this will be
uploaded so for the one who just pinged
saying can we get this
you will have it i mean there's no
proprietary information here it's all
everybody's learnings you know so we'll
share this don't worry about it
um the minute i say you know i'm going
to share the presentation people how
i'll get this presentation let me go
through it later don't do that listen to
what i'm saying
so kiss uh is you know how you can
keep it short and simple if i have to
give you an example my name is vinay
trivedi
i'm a gujarati i'm born and brought up
in bangalore
my family my parents live with me i've
done my education here i've done my
master's from xlri
i like traveling uh in my you know free
time
i just made an impromptu one but it's as
simple as that
right that's the first second section
what have you
done okay um
i will sort of share a little little tip
to all of you today
a lot of hr folks will kill me for this
because i know this is going to be out
in public domain
but for us as hr folks do you know
ladies and gentlemen when we go on an
interview
it's like a blind date we don't know who
you guys are
but what we are doing is we are using
your
not so focused approach or your lack of
common sense
in tricking you or making it a miserable
conversation
because you will tell some things or
blurt out something because you're not
well prepared
and we'll pick that up and we'll start
hammering you on that
right so for us more than you for us
it's a blind date
right we don't even know who you are we
ask you questions or tell me about your
background so the minute you start
telling all other stories
they'll be like okay so i'll catch him
on this oh your hobby is
uh playing football when did you last
play football let's say
five years back really is that your
hobby is this who you are
you know that we actually pick up on on
things that you go for
right so it's a little tip so be very
confident when you go for interviews
because we don't know who you are
whatever you reveal is what we know and
therefore
it is in your interest to reveal things
that you want the interviewer to ask you
questions on
so the next section is what have you
done right um
[Music]
three or four key areas that you worked
on this is
these points and what you should prepare
on when you are
uh sort of you know preparing for
interview conversation so three or four
key areas like for example
in my current role i'm working as a
manual tester my my job responsibility
is to
go through jira look at the task
allocations i then have to
uh go through scrum master blah blah
blah you know three or four
critical areas right what roles have you
done
possibly in descending order when uh
when i say descending order it's the
latest first i'll just take two seconds
and
sipping in some water i've been shouting
literally
roles in descending order one failure
one achievement one learning
you have it if you've written your essay
so you'll have multiple
things to share now what is this prep
formula p-r-e-p
it's a formula actually you know it's
not preparation i know a lot of you
thought
what have you done you have to prepare
no prep is a formula
and prep stands for p stands for point
r stands for reason e stands for example
p stands for point which means
that when you talk if you talk in a prep
format
people will believe you for example
um i love
india because there is so much
diversity of people food and weather
example the weather in goa is amazing i
would want to be there
therefore i love india point
reason example point right prep is a
formula
now you could use it as prp you could
use it as pep
or you could use it as prep as in you
could have just point
reason point or you could uh
have it as a point reason
example point or you could have it as
point example point
prep full form is point
reason example and
restate the same point so it becomes
that much more
valid it becomes that much more powerful
right
what have you done is critical after you
tell about your personal background
uh what you have done
is gonna be somebody asked me can i
repeat so prep is point
reason example point uh after you talk
about your personal background it's
important that you start talking about
what you've done
in an interview they'll tell tell me
about yourself you finished that
okay tell me what have you done what's
your current role so you will start so
this is how you prepare for it right the
third section
and these are largely the only sections
that you know
you can mix and match and have it in
multiple ways but this is what it is
value addition
right what is it that you are going to
add value
in that particular job for that for you
to know the job description is very
important
like i mentioned earlier read the jdwell
map areas
in the jd that you already worked on
because the jd would have said
three to five years in this uh so many
years in this should have worked on
jira should have worked on blah blah
blah multiple things right
mentally map it to the areas of work
right so when they ask you how are you
going to add value
oh i'm going to add value because i told
you i have worked
on this area and i believe this is what
is there in this job description
which will help me deliver better in
this role therefore you know so you
actually talk about
specific examples my whole conversation
is on examples and those examples come
through your
arms eliminations comes through multiple
things because
the more you are able to give examples
the easier it is for the interviewer to
believe
that you are not bullshitting but you
you're actually stating the facts
and that's why examples are important
right so
value addition will have two sections
one is what value will you add
the second section is one area that you
have possibly not worked on which you
will tell the interviewer
by the way these are five things i'm
going to add value on
why this role is important for me is
because there is this area that i have
not worked
that's going to be the growth area for
me so you know
you are actually saying how i am adding
value and you are also adding value
because a lot of times interviewer also
asks oh so tell me you're not going to
do anything new
how will how will this role help you
grow how will this role help you in your
professional career
we are saying like oh it will help me
because you can't tell oh it's because
giving me more money
right you will obviously not say that
but how do you say that
you say at least something that you've
possibly not worked on
that you want to work on right um
so this is your value addition the next
section largely is a technical question
section
right now technical question is just a
uh is is just a sense that i'm trying to
give you
i'm not saying that they're gonna it's
not just about
your coding technicalities but technical
question is
anything which they can ask you
specifics on like favorite subject
favorite sport right uh area of interest
right like for freshers they'll say
what's your favorite subject
that's the easiest bait okay it's a bait
you say oh my favorite subject is
economics okay economics that's my
favorite subject
so tell me about marginal diminishing
utility and you'll be like oh i learned
that in class 12 i don't even remember
that [ __ ] now
right technical question is you know
when they ask you these technical
questions
okay um so or it could be
your actual technology related questions
right when you get into this section
you should know what you say very well
you should know one latest development
in that area because
you are telling this is my my you know
say favorite subject this is my favorite
skill
this is my favorite technology this is
my favorite area of interest
you are saying that because you're
saying that you should know what is
happening around
i i can't say that oh i love this
particular
technology i love machine learning okay
so what's the latest in machine learning
algorithm
um i've done a certification i don't
remember
is it going to make your argument valid
no it's not
that's why it's important that you know
what you're saying
say what you know very well know what
you're saying
and keep one latest development ready
very important
the last thing and that's a trap again a
bait
or a trap avoid talking of trending
topics
just because something is trending do
not screw yourself up by saying that
because that will put you in a difficult
situation
right that's one section um
the last section is googly googly is
anything that they can ask you that you
do not know the answer to
it's a simple math i've put it up on the
screen as well
you know answer you are in doubt don't
answer you don't know definitely don't
answer
right as simple and sweet as that so
there are only these
five sections right
you think of any interview it will be
in some way related to these four or
five areas itself
any interview conversation that you've
attended so far right any interview
right so i've bucketed this for you to
get a
simple perspective right keep it short
and simple when it comes to personal
background
use the prep formula which is your point
reason example point formula
to make sure that your argument is solid
or your statement is solid people
believe it
right use as many examples as possible
you can use them because if you written
an essay you will have a lot of them
with you already
so you can use them um and
when you don't know or when you are in
doubt
have a smile and say i'm sorry i don't
know about this
then they may come and ask you oh why
don't you try you confidently say
while i'm not aware i will give it an
attempt but i'm not sure
there's nothing wrong in saying i don't
know
but what have you done oh i have done
this this this
then they ask you one more question oh i
don't know okay what value addition
you're going to bring
oh i don't know i've not read the jd
well okay tell me about your hobbies
oh i don't have any now if for
everything you say i don't know then god
bless you then definitely
i don't know why even there in the
interview right i don't know can only be
used in areas that you genuinely don't
know
and that can only happen when
only question but for
help you in preparing well right that's
why this
this whole slide okay
phew okay
i will um also give you a brief about
uh how do you build a linkedin profile
and then we'll quickly jump into q a
i have time for it's a one hour 15
minute session
i will extend it by five six minutes do
not worry
um and i'll answer as many questions as
possible so you know
just keep keep listening and keep your
questions ready okay um
[Music]
in your linkedin stop writing i'm a java
evangelist
stop writing i'm a technological
enthusiast
right you have an introduction section
keep it simple
designation education current stage
accomplishment skills
designation for example in my case
designation global chro
education masters in hr current stage
in in my case if i'm hiring for my
company i'll say hiring
techies if i'm looking for opportunities
i'll say looking for a job
you know accomplishments major
accomplishments
major awards right and key skills if you
want to mention
you don't have to write all of them
together you could
definitely designation education and
current stage first three are critical
the last two may not be in the intro
section
right again there's no right or wrong
ladies and gentlemen
i've just used my experience and common
sense to make it simple
for people to understand right or it
could also be a one-line statement
i am a java professional with nine years
experience looking for opportunities
i am a java professional with 10 years
experience working with this
organization
it could also be a one line statement
there is no harm in that so
it could either be organized as
designation education current stage
blah blah blah and uh you know if
one line statement is one line statement
if you're transitioning in between jobs
you can say
uh you know say i'm a i'm a ruby on
rails uh
i'm i'm eight years experience in ruby
on rails currently looking for
uh newer opportunities currently looking
for new jobs currently looking for
new adventures you can just you know
it's okay to mention that in your this
thing
right so um in the one line statement
you write like that
in the first time in the first step i
mean the first
version you write senior ro developer
education you know whatever education it
is current stage
looking for jobs in ror
so you know while again i'm telling i'm
repeating again
there's no right or wrong okay this is
just a simple way of sharing you may not
want to implement it
or you may want to you just take a call
on yourself right
all of us are adults right the third way
is just to write
designation and current stage simple
straightforward
senior ro developer looking for an
opportunity
senior java developer
uh currently working here just that
that's also fine you know
cut the clutter stop the crap let me
just straight away right to whatever
whatever
it is you can also do that by the way
right we are hr folks you know we tend
to talk a lot
of course all of you know that we tend
to talk a lot i've been talking for the
last 50 minutes
and i'm still so excited at 9 55 pm in
india
right so that's how we are right but you
don't have to be that you can
cut the chase and and come to the
straight point as well no problem in
that
all right three things to remember while
you are building your profile
on social media platform anything you
write
this is my thumb rule you should have
done it at least 10 times
you can't be just because your college
alumni association called you to give a
lecture you cannot suddenly
write on your linkedin saying i am a
guest lecturer
right and i see a lot of people who do
that so i'm just sharing this
anything you write you should have done
it at least for 10 times
or at least for a minimum one year
right it is important now freshers will
say how will we write that
so you will only write that looking for
or currently working on
instead of saying that rich experience
in
for freshers instead of saying you know
they've just joined they've
written rich experience in java usually
currently working in java
right so and again
like i said even in the beginning i
don't believe in global jargons i can
definitely use a language that will be
very complex
which you will not be able to comprehend
which we have been taught how to
sort of use to dissipate information uh
when we are
doing these sessions i don't believe in
that right
unless your profession is that you don't
use any fancy words keep it simple keep
it straight forward
it's as simple as that okay oh god
too much information too much
information
if you want to build your personal brand
you have to do three things and why am i
saying
if you have to build your personal brand
this was for a job or this is for a job
hunt
today everybody is looking for a brand
ambassador
okay somebody wants me to go to the
previous slide i'll
okay take a screenshot but i can share
this as well
i'm never going to share this so don't
worry and this will be there in recorded
version for you to
go through it later as well
if you want to build a personal brand
you have to be innovative
you have to engage and you have to
experiment i don't think we have too
much time to cover this part of it but
i'll give you
why i've put this up here
you are representing a brand
you when you are talking to people
and that brand will be reflective of
things you say
and the way you say yes karthik
chintamani i will share this
presentation
simply learn will send it to you all of
you on an email
uh hopefully right uh i think we should
be able to do yes
because we will be glad to do that super
so you will you know sort of innovate
experiment and engage because
when you do something innovative like
for example this session right i don't
know what you people thought
you know how i'm not going to come and
teach you on how you should hunt for a
tech job i'm not even a techie i'm an hr
person
right but i thought it's important that
i give you a perspective because all of
you are smart enough to build on that
perspective
what i've done is i've helped you
declutter and organize yourself
comb your hair become smart that's what
i've done
i haven't given you any technical
details because that's not my job
because each one's
you know your own individual self right
how do you innovate
we often keep thinking oh how do i
approach this person but i just go write
an email they'll say no
send a message they'll say no that's all
nothing more than that
so you know it is important that you
experiment and innovate
right i don't even know when the last
time you experimented something ask this
question to yourself
and engage genuinely when you write to
somebody saying that
oh you know when i keep getting these
linkedin requests right and that's for
jobs
i was looking for leaders and i saw your
stellar profile therefore i'm reaching
out to you
i don't even care for that message right
so engage genuinely i'm not going to
tell you how you should be genuine
use common sense you will know how you
should be genuine okay
you know you have to cut the clutter
right like i said overload in the first
line right
these are some tips that i thought
everybody should know
because that helps you in becoming
calmer the minute you're calmer you
become more confident the minute you're
more confident you remember
more things the minute you remember more
things you will be able to
answer them well so that's why cutting
the clever is important right
like for example watch news only for
five minutes don't make yourself anxious
by
continuously tracking news i know a lot
of us you know every time
we have so many notifications coming on
our mobile phone it's insane it just
screws up mentally don't do that
right don't go overboard with anything
right you know when
when people suddenly got this locked
down lifestyle
first one month i could see everybody is
a chef
everybody is a gardener everybody is a
singer
after two months everybody is back to
normal right because
everybody went so overboard right it
just didn't sustain so don't go
overboard with anything you do
right uh learning if you do not have
two implementable solutions please
refrain this is to the certifications
part
right smile and take it easy think about
how you can avoid formal lead action
very important because sometimes we
apply for a job because we
we fear oh that fellow has got a job
there i should also apply
don't do that apply for a job when you
think you want to apply for one
don't apply for a job because somebody
is applying for a job formal
right be aware be focused
that is very important i know i've
rushed through this slide
you can take up i'll just give one
second take a screenshot if somebody
wants to take a screenshot
but these are things that have helped me
in conversations and by the way
i've just moved from one from one job to
another job so i've just finished an
interview process
where i've actually implemented
everything that i've just told here in
the presentation so you know it's very
fresh for me to
also tell you okay
that was my presentation i should
stop screen share
and let's go for questions great
for more is fear of missing out for more
fear of missing out
we have a huge number of questions but
uh
we'll only be able to take a percentage
of them so i apologize in advance
uh but uh speaking of another
acronym uh vicati asks about
smart and can you talk about
it with the smart app
comes out look um so ducati asks about
another acronym which is smart
uh can you address that
smart what was that
um came in from my youtube channel
i can't hear you again you're i think
microphone problem or you can possibly
type that
if you don't mind sorry oh
okay
okay while he is doing this um
a lot of you are asking about gap years
right uh
my simple point on gap years to anybody
who's had a gap
is you should be able to tell why you
took that gap if it means that you took
that gap
to prepare for something and failed talk
about it if you've taken a
gap and not done anything tell that
saying that i took a break i honestly
have not done anything i'm back in the
market
right my approach to any gap year
is to be truthful eight out of
10 people will think that you are insane
when you
when you just need um
one job so it doesn't matter
it's called sorry you've put that up or
it's gone up again
yeah i did
yes i did uh
see it in chat oh it's in the chat
window okay i'm just seeing it
i can't see
it on the chat it's a question from the
ask about the acronym smart the acronyms
uh
smart what is smart mean is that what
you're asking
smart so smart is
a specific measurable
achievable goals right
so when you set very very specific
uh goals when you have measurable
targets
and your achievable results that becomes
i hope that's answered the question okay
uh we have questions from people who are
switching from one domain
to another and um
for example a aerospace engineer with
eight
years of experience who is studying
machine learning
so how would he position that
on a resume so anybody who
wants to change career tracks right at
least
the way i see it a lot of times we want
an opportunity
but at the same time we want to protect
our pay scales as well
um but we want someone to give us an
opportunity as well
right you can't be sailing on two boats
so
if you want to change career tracks you
need to understand
that you have to start from scratch
which means
nobody's taking away your experience in
terms of maturity
as a professional but in terms of
exposure to that particular job that
you're doing
you are still a pressure so anybody who
wants to change tracks
be willing to do an internship for three
months six months free of cost
and you are sure to convert that into an
opportunity if you've done your
transition well right easier uh
difficult i don't know but it's a short
shot
to get an opportunity in that field a
lot of people you know they do
certifications and they say oh now i
should become a project manager or now i
should become an ml expert
it doesn't work that way so you know
try getting opportunities in terms of
internships
and it's not a bad thing to be an intern
at 10 years experience as well
it only shows that you're willing to
unlearn and reload that'll
um and it's an interesting one
just to match a job description should
somebody
add skills that they're not confident
about
so if there are skills that you are not
confident about
there is a reason for it either you have
not worked enough on that
or you have not um or you have not
really
done well even if you worked on that
right it is best
to add in a manner where you say that on
a scale of one to five
this skill will be one or two rating the
minute you add ratings to the skill set
then they know that you are not very
good at it and they'll obviously
question you basis that so it's okay to
mention but mention that you're
you're a novice you're a professional uh
you're a fresher
write that so people are aware of that
that's all
okay deepak asks a question
i think a lot of people can relate to
which is uh
when he used to go for that in-person
interview
at a high close rate getting jobs but
now on
online interviews the success rate is
it's an interesting one right you've
attended this webinar online
and you still thought that you were with
me
in most of the slides right so an
online interview is as effective as in
person
what makes the difference is your
confidence and your preparation
to talk about who you are that's all
don't worry whether
it's online offline doesn't matter right
if you
if you think that you could relate to
the slides that means
i have effectively spoken to you online
and that's how an interview is to be
able to effectively put your thoughts
across
and when can you do that you can do that
when you're prepared well
and i've given you enough tips to
prepare well
okay um so much ask a question
about which ranks
more or rates more highly with the
interviewer
a higher educational background or to 10
years of experience
i think for any interviewer who you are
as a person makes the most difference
it doesn't matter if you're 10 years
experience and you don't know what
you've been doing
too bad you will not get the job you are
a qualified professional
have stellar academic achievements but
if somebody asks you something about
your academics and you're not able to
answer
too bad you will still not get your job
what is important is
to tell your story confidently
for them to believe who you are now the
next follow-up question to that is
or do you mean that education doesn't
matter at all of course it matters
but if you've done something that should
only speak so for example
i am not an engineer i'm a commerce
graduate and i've done management
education
but a lot of my colleagues fellow
colleagues in hr are
engineering graduates who've done
management education they are much
sharper than who i am
so am i going to say that oh i'm not as
sharp because i'm a commerce graduate of
course not
i'm going to talk of what i've done how
i've grown how i've learned so what is
important is to showcase who you are
we have a few technical questions about
resumes themselves how long should a
resume be
should it have rich graphics on it
and it should be formatted so that uh
automated
application tracking systems can can
pull it in
what are your thoughts on these so i
think it's important that your keywords
are are definitely there on your resume
which is
if you are say a roi developer and there
are five things in ror make sure that
you mention all those five things
because
your application tracking system is
built on the intelligence to pick those
words
and map it so definitely you should have
that
i'm not for or against a graphic or a
visually representative profile but
i think what is important then the
semantics
of the layout while the layout is is
basic
it should be neat clean legible visible
not too cluttered
but beyond that what is important is the
work that you have genuinely done that
is mentioned there and not global
jargons so if there's anything that you
have to work on your profile
make it genuine make it as if you are
representing yourself
in person when somebody reads that
profile
we have a question from sushma in the
youtube audience who asks
how do you overcome interview fear
oh sushma i think you know um
when i understood that for the
interviewer
it's a blind date i've been the most
confident
and the fear is often because
we believe we are not prepared the day
you think now
i'll give you an example and this is a
very funny and unrelated example
you are going into a party or a wedding
or uh or celebrating an occasion
and somebody comes and compliments you
oh your hairstyle looks good
you are suddenly very confident about
yourself and you will start walking very
confidently
right because your effort has been
recognized
it's a very simple example the same
thing happens in an interview
if you have a lot of arms and ammunition
you will go in an interview ask me
anything
i have 10 failures 10 success stories 10
learnings
i know everything ask me the confidence
will drive how you answer questions so
you will fear if you are underprepared
and if you are still fearing after being
prepared well because that's in your
nature i think you should smile and tell
that i'm a little nervous
i may stammer a bit please excuse me
but i will definitely attempt to give
answers to the best of my ability
that will put the interviewer on the
back foot okay the person is told that
he or she is nervous let me be slightly
kind he will he or she will try and make
you more comfortable
so state that in the beginning so people
are aware simple as that
great um sajid has a question which is
an interesting one
how does one avoid social stigma or
embarrassment on linkedin
and you're starting to look for
opportunities or you're out of a
job your friends your family your ex
colleagues
people are going to look at your
linkedin profile people who know you
they're going to start seeing oh he's
out of a job or he's looking for
a new position how would you
advise such eating people like in that
position
to overcome that feeling i will give you
my personal example
uh it's a it's a great question i was
out of a job
for about two or three months in between
and i was
out of a job without a new job so i was
technically i left one job i had not
found another one and i was searching
for opportunities
every day i would wake up and apply to
10
relevant jobs and one day i actually
was just flipping in coffee and i i
wrote on linkedin saying that
i've applied to 800 jobs i've got
50 interview calls i've not got selected
in a single one but even today i
continue to apply for my jobs actually
flaunted my joblessness on on linkedin
i was amazed at the support that came to
me
when they read that and i had people
calling me
are you all right i hope you're doing
fine don't worry it's just a face
and i'm actually sitting in coffee and
just writing a linkedin post because i'm
just you know expressing my state of
mind
right so if you're out of job be
confident that you're out of job
it's okay it doesn't matter uh you know
of what people say what people
would think because they're not going to
come and pay you your salary they're not
going to come and pay you your allowance
they're not even going to come and check
on you
they're only going to talk so if that's
impacting you ignore them
you know watch news for five minutes
watch social media also for five minutes
when you're in that state don't worry
too much about it
we think that the people in our networks
are may look down on us because we're
looking for jobs
but the other aspect is that they may
look and say
oh i've been waiting for you to be
available here's a job opportunity for
you
absolutely absolutely flaunt it it's
okay to flaunt it
we are running out of time i think you
said you
would be able to stay a few minutes
longer um so i'm going to
ask maybe a couple more
questions we have a general um
topic or theme among some of the
questions about people who are
non-technical
do not have a technical degree but want
to move into a technical field
um what would you advise them about
how to position themselves to employers
what things emphasize
in making that particular kind of
transition
so like i said any transition is like
a plane taking off right it's not going
to be easy
it's it'll take a lot of efforts you
know to gain the thrust
it takes a lot of efforts right and even
to go down it takes a lot of efforts
right cruising is the best time so when
you're transitioning
it is more like the trust that you need
to gain which means
that in a normal scenario if you were
doing five things
in a transition phase you have to do 15
things just because you
are transitioning and that effort means
that
you will look at projects you will look
for internships you can look at learning
opportunities
your focus has to be that i want to do
this work
and not can i make this much money out
of it right you cannot sail on both
boats so you have to have to have
maximized efforts
when you're transitioning people will
not believe you in general people
do not like to believe anybody's
transition oh you must be
a fool to actually leave such a good
career and move there
i mean they want to understand that
there is a reason why you are deciding
to transition
so you don't need to have to explain to
them but keep
you know maximizing your efforts very
critical to find
projects internship free work
opportunities where you get to learn
because that learning will get you a job
very good
um by the way in general
i'm going to assume that everything you
have said applies not just for tech jobs
but for
anybody who's looking for any job yes
absolutely absolutely and there's
nothing that i've told that people don't
know
i think all of us know this it's just
that they're organizing their wardrobe
so they'll be able to pick up the right
set of
you know clothes when they have to go
out
uh ishmael and our linkedin audience i
think this may be our
last question due to time um
how would you get through to a specific
company
if you want to apply for a job
how would you um so
he's expressing some frustration about
applying through job boards
and web portals
when looking to get to a particular
company
so what would the strategy be if you
said for example i want to work
for um
therapy and
how do you get to a company in
particular
you know i think uh sometimes we beat
ourselves
up for no fault of ours because somebody
is not responding
somebody is not engaging it's not your
fault and a lot of times people
get very disillusioned in the job search
process when
you know they don't get responses they
get very rejected saying that
oh i have applied to 50 jobs nobody is
responding to me don't don't do that to
you because it's not on you
it's on people who have not possibly
responded to you but what i would do
like i said when i was in a job search
stage
every day morning i would wake up smell
the coffee
apply to 10 relevant jobs if out of
those 10 there are two places that i
really want to work in
i will go to linkedin look up for two or
three relevant people
try to write an email to them saying
that hey apply to this job could you
refer me
could you help me etc etc i would also
try to talk in my network if anybody
knows anybody in that company
to see if somebody can put a word
through
basically what i'm saying is i'm trying
in different
aspects and angles to get through people
because i want that
and even after that if you don't land
that opportunity
don't worry it's not that you will never
land that opportunity
but what is important is to not beat
yourself up because
when you beat yourself up you become low
on confidence when you become low on
confidence you're not
able to be your best at interview
conversations
and you don't want to be not at your
best when
when you go for any interview because
it's a job
after all that you get
what wonderful advice so that
is pretty much all the time we have for
q a and i apologize
to everybody who asked really great
questions that we could not get to
but um i'm going to to
move on to
one last item here before we
close out the session
recording of this everybody get the
presentation so don't worry about it
just
[Music]
and when i get the um presentation
from vinay i will make sure that i send
that link out if i need to send a
separate email
we'll definitely do that so uh a quick
second poll
the approach
to looking for work looking for a new
position looking for
the next to step up in your career
and how to present yourself how to tell
your story
okay so we talked about
how to tell your story how to present
yourself
um how to take that next step up in your
career
we're also interested in finding out
what you'd like
most to learn next to round out your
skill set
and when you'd like to do that so
the poll is over i will
share the result
and we find that
people are very interested in data
science
ai also
project management and business skills
and a large number of you more than half
of you said that you would like to start
right away
that's a good sign because today is
always a good time
it's time to start so
let me at this point and
let me remind people how to get in touch
with
and i want to thank you renee for being
here today this has been an
excellent presentation very good
response from the
from the audience and they're going to
be looking forward to getting that
recording in that copy of the powerpoint
absolutely thank you very much simply
learn for
having me over thanks charles for
patiently sitting through
uh this one and and and also helping me
in troubleshooting
and uh audience you can reach out to me
on linkedin
i will be delayed but i i'll definitely
be
never late i will answer your questions
write your questions i'll be happy to
answer them
and good luck be confident prepare well
do well
and god bless you okay thank you so much
we're going to um we've dropped
into the chat throughout the
presentation links to
the program skill up which is something
that simply learn
introduced about a year ago and
uh we've already had more more than
500 000 half a million people who've
become involved in it it provides access
to our self-study skills
there's actually over 600 of the skills
that are in the
skill up program now this is a free
version
of our self study materials and
we invite all of you and i will drop
that into the chat one more time
when you complete a skill up course you
get a certificate of completion which
documents that you did this work
uh different from our regular programs
and regular certificates which
um are more official
representation of your skills but
still something that you can use to
document your progress
and your willingness to learn so that
i'm going to also point out that
our next webinar is one week
thursday of next week and on the subject
of
cyber security so if you are working in
cyber security if you are interested in
becoming
cyber security expert you'll hear
from the microsoft's leaders
in that field and he'll talk about
what the emerging threat profiles look
like and how that will affect
people's careers please ignore the sound
of my
telephone ringing in the background and
i drop the link to the next webinar in
the chat as well
so please feel free to connect with us
on our
social media channels facebook twitter
and linkedin
and this concludes the webinar we thank
you all for being here we thank janae
uh very much for being with us
and we hope to see you at future simply
learn webinars as well as
invite you into the simply learn learner
community
thanks again thank you thank you
[Music]
you